[Música]
a vida na roça será árdua mas era farta
tínhamos de tudo um pouco uma mão e
aipim banana milho e milhares de outras
coisas mas eu só consigo eu só conseguia
pensar no quanto éramos pobres porque
não tínhamos pão e sim café tinha que
ter bom
a minha mãe trazia farinha e fazemos
bolos fazemos biscoitos mas não tínhamos
achocolatado não tínhamos pão só fala
não é minha é essa falar na verdade é um
trecho de uma avaliação final de uma vez
de uma disciplina que o ministro aqui na
universidade feito por um estudante não
é muito comum né você ter uma avaliação
final de uma disciplina escrita assim um
relato na primeira pessoa a maioria das
disciplinas não funciona assim
as minhas também não funcionava até
muito pouco tempo atrás
sou educadora ambiental quando ele se
forma para ser educador ambiental aqui
no brasil e para ser honesto em outros
lugares do mundo também existe uma
grande chance de que essa nossa formação
vai ser muito influenciada por um
educador brasileiro chamado paulo freire
paulo freire é pra mim um dos maiores
patrimônios do brasil
para vocês terem uma idéia uma pesquisa
realizada em 2016 pela london school of
economics demonstrou que um dos livros
do paulo freire pedagogia do oprimido é
o terceiro livro mais lido no planeta na
área de ciências sociais
uma outra pesquisa realizada no mesmo
ano essa por um projeto chamado open
syllabus que estuda as universidades nos
países de língua inglesa constatou que
entre os cem livros mais requisitados
nessas universidades existe apenas um
livro brasileiro é o pedagogia do
oprimido
quando eles restringiram essa busca
especificamente para a área de educação
que é a área do livro eles constataram
então que
pedagogia do oprimido é o segundo livro
mais requisitado pelas universidades nos
países de língua inglesa é muita coisa
né gente
a gente não precisa de validação
internacional para valorizar o que a
gente tem aqui mas também é legal saber
dessas coisas né
é uma das contribuições que o paulo
freire traz na sua obra dentre as várias
contribuições é o conceito de educação
bancário
vou pedir para vocês fazerem um esforço
de imaginação
imaginem uma escola imagine uma sala de
aula os estudantes sentados chega o
professor fala o seu conteúdo
a aula acaba ele vai embora chega o
próximo professor fala o seu conteúdo
a aula acaba ele vai embora e assim os
professores passam os dias passam as
semanas passam os meses passam os anos
passam ea tradição pedagógica se mantém
basicamente a mesma
o sujeito da ação é o professor cabe aos
estudantes um papel passivo de receber
aquelas são que é feita pelo professor
quando eu tomei contato com o conceito
de educação bancária isso era final dos
anos 90 eu estava fazendo o meu mestrado
aquilo me incomodou mas assim como não
me pegou de verdade já no começo dos
anos 2000 quando eu comecei a minha
carreira como professor de ensino
fundamental e de ensino superior
e aquele incômodo me pegou porque eu não
queria que as minhas aulas fossem
bancárias eu queria que ela fosse um
mínimo bancários possível
foi aí que eu aprendi uma coisa
importante é muito mais fácil criticá
educação bancária do que de fato fazer
alguma coisa que seja significativamente
diferente mas se aquele encontro me
acompanhou longo do tempo porque eu não
sabia como fazer eu sabia por outro lado
o que eu queria eu queria que os
estudantes se envolvessem ele se
interessassem que eles participassem das
minhas disciplinas que eles criassem
coisas
uma imagem que me ajudava que me ajudava
bastante a entender o que eu queria era
a imagem das aulas de educação física
vocês já imaginaram seus aula de
educação física fosse administrados da
mesma maneira que as aulas tradicionais
outras disciplinas então imaginem
primeira aula aula de salto em altura o
professor ou professora vai com os
estudantes para a pista de atletismo
os estudantes entram nas suas cadeiras e
o professor fala da teoria da dinâmica
mecânica do salto em altura e ele vai só
uma vez saltou duas vezes solta três
vezes essa aula acaba ele vai agora
trabalhar com a próxima turma trabalho é
o vôlei é o saque
os estudantes chegam na quadra central
nas suas cadeiras esse professor ou
professora fazem uma abordagem teórica
sobre o saque sobre a mecânica sobre a
dinâmica do saque ele sacou uma vez saca
duas vezes a cada três vezes
imaginaram como vai tá esse professor no
final do dia
exausto vai ter exausto porque foi ele
que fez tudo cabe aos estudantes esse
papel de praticamente observar mas as
aulas de educação física não são assim
nas aulas de educação física os
estudantes envolve eles correm eles
pulam eles acabam a aula suados cansados
e era essa a imagem que eu queria trazer
pra minha disciplina
eu queria que no final das missas das
minhas aulas os estudantes tivessem
cansados que tivessem suados ou como no
final de uma de uma oficina de pintura
que eles tivessem sujos de tinta ou no
final de uma oficina de escultura com
cerâmica que eles tivessem sujos de
barro porque eles se envolveram com
aquilo lá então é eu queria criar um
espaço nos quais no qual os estudantes
tivessem a possibilidade de produzir
obras de arte com o seu pensamento na
minha disciplina esse suor é metafórico
a matéria prima é invisível a tinta o
barro são invisíveis porque a matéria
prima da minha disciplina são os nossos
pensamentos nossa inteligência as nossas
reflexões mas eu queria criar espaços
nos quais os estudantes pudessem criar
verdadeiras obras de arte com seus
pensamentos
essa oportunidade me ver
aí o bastante recentemente já aqui na
universidade em 2016 quando me foi feita
a oferta de ministrar a disciplina de
educação ambiental e cidadania que é a
minha área de formação
foi então que o produto criei uma
disciplina fundamental em dois
princípios o primeiro deles o diálogo
isso significa na prática que todas as
minhas aulas acontecem por meio de
metodologias participativas
mais uma vez isso significa que nenhum
dos 15 encontros que eu tenho ao longo
da disciplina com os meus estudantes ao
longo do semestre
vocês vão me ver lá na frente trazendo
para os estudantes uma narrativa
completa pronta e acabada sobre os
problemas do mundo sobre os problemas
ambientais no mundo e sobre como você
educa alguém pra esses problemas
ambientais
diferentemente disso eu queria criar
espaços de diálogo com os estudantes a
criarem as suas próprias compreensões
que eles criassem as suas esculturas de
pensamento
o segundo princípio bastante é
relacionado a esse primeiro princípio a
criação de espaço nos quais os
estudantes pudessem ter a oportunidade
de se expressar na primeira pessoa eu
percebi ao longo da minha experiência na
escola e na universidade que esses
ambientes oferecem pouquíssimos espaços
para a gente que é pra que a gente se
expresse na primeira pessoa
isso significa que aqui a gente fala
principalmente na terceira pessoa
ou seja a gente fala de alguém ou a
gente fala sobre alguma coisa que se
alguém falou isso é importante
não me entendam mal isso é importante eu
quero que os meus estudantes fazem sobre
paulo freire
eu quero que eles falem sobre as teorias
do paulo freire sobre pedagogia do
oprimido a educação bancária etc
mas eu achava que só isso era muito
pouco eu queria saber como eles
dialogavam com essas teorias como que
eles eram afetados por elas
então na prática nos trabalhos que eu
dou na disciplina eu criei um espaço
generoso ao lado das questões mais
objetivas e mais técnicas que eu trago a
respeito dos materiais que a gente
tudo os livros que a gente lê os textos
os filmes que a gente assiste músicas
que a gente ouve obras de arte que a
gente analisa
eu criei ao lado desses espaços dessas
questões
um espaço generoso cruzado para os
estudantes se expressarem na primeira
pessoa então eu pergunto pra eles
o que que a lei do estudo desse material
que suscitou de pensamento e eu peço pra
eles nas aulas para prestarem atenção
nos pensamentos que emergem nas suas
cabeças enquanto eles estão estudando
esses pensamentos muitas vezes são
fugazes
eles são efêmeros eles são muito rápidos
então a gente tem que prestar atenção
neles eu falo captura e esses
pensamentos registro nesses pensamentos
e tragam para a aula né
tragam para as nossas rodas de conversa
os seus pensamentos o que você pensa me
interessa
quando a gente cria uma disciplina com
uma metodologia que é diferente da
tradicional
a gente gera estranhamento é normal e
natural teve um estudante que num
trabalho dele relatou pra mim que quando
ele começou quando a disciplina começou
e começou a entender o que significava o
fato da disciplina acontecer por meio de
metodologias participativas
ele sentiu repulsa repulsa mas que ao
longo do tempo à medida que a disciplina
foi se desenrolando ele aprendeu
ele percebeu que era a a nossa nossa
intenção e que ele aprendeu então a
diferença entre assistir uma aula e
participar de uma teve um outro
estudante que relatou um trabalho que
ele se sentiu impelido que a disciplina
o motivou a extrair o máximo de si a
fazer o máximo
a despeito do fato dela não não não
criar aquele ambiente de medo da prova
sabe aquele aquela sensação de medo que
a gente fiquem antes de uma prova gente
já me disse que não tem prova
mesmo assim ele sentiu impelido a
extrair o máximo de si porque ele sabia
que as suas contribuições em estar
presentes nos produtos finais da
disciplina né
os materiais que a gente fosse produzir
com a disciplina teve uma estudante
relatou que com a disciplina
ela aprendeu a leitura a importância da
leitura de um bom texto e mais do que
isso ela aprendeu a importância de não
se apequenar diante de um texto difícil
por que estudar é assim estudar exige
dedicação exige esforço e às vezes um
texto para ser compreendido e precisa
ser lido duas vezes três vezes quatro
vezes e que isso é normal
uma outra estudante relatou no final da
nossa disciplina que ela nunca tinha
prestado atenção no teor dos seus
pensamentos
então vejam quando comecei a receber
esses trabalhos de volta e comecei a ler
os relatos de estudantes eu comecei a
pensar em quanta coisa disciplina estava
promovendo e aí eu comecei a entender
como as nossas disciplinas podem muito
mais do que a gente imagina e que a
gente precisa conversar sobre isso
quando a gente estuda para ser honesto
de educação ambiental
a gente estuda basicamente a relação do
humano com a natureza de uma maneira
mais específica a gente estuda a relação
do ocidente com a natureza e de como que
as escolhas feitas pelo ocidente
historicamente causam consequências
sobre a natureza sobre os povos da
natureza e dos povos que vivem na
natureza e sobre nós mesmos então a
gente estuda sobre capitalismo a gente
estuda sobre colonização teorias do
progresso teresa do desenvolvimento ea
razão pela qual a gente tudo essas
teorias é que elas em geral desvaloriza
principalmente aqui no brasil o que nós
temos e que nós somos
elas valorizam a enorme diversidade
social e na diversidade modo de vida
existentes no brasil e valoriza a nossa
biodiversidade
nossa natureza o brasil é um país mega
diverso e essa mega diversidade quase
que não tem valor
no discurso ambiental global por conta
disso quando a gente pensa ou encontra
um lugar que a gente considera
desenvolvido a gente encontra um lugar
socialmente padronizado e ecologicamente
degradado mas como eu falei pra vocês eu
não quero só que os estudantes se
apropriem das teorias que eles aprendam
teorias eu quero saber como eles
dialogam com ela como que eles são
afetados por elas
a vida na roça era farda era árdua mas
era faca
tínhamos de tudo um pouco uma mão em
aipim banana milho milhares de outras
coisas
só que eu só conseguia pensar no quanto
era uns pobres porque não tínhamos pão a
minha mãe trazia farinha e fazemos bolos
e fazemos biscoitos mas não tínhamos
achocolatado e não tínhamos pão
hoje nós temos pão e solo nu
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]